Hello everyone. My name is Mohammed Barry,
I'm from New Gandhi. I am a young person living
with HIV for 11 years. My concern about this
World Cup next year is that whether the jobs
being initiated will be sustained and where
those people will not be put in risk because
right now we are in crisis and we talk about
[inaudible] crisis and I'm so concerned. If
this bridge [inaudible] has not been completed.
How about the jobs that are already been in
place and people have hopes and I tell them
hoping that their parents will bring something
that will sustain throughout their lives.
That's my concern about it. And I know with
regards to HIV I don't to become [inaudible]
around the world bringing HIV prevention to
those that are living with HIV. But I'm just
asking where South Africa has these strategies
to make sure that there money to their people
[inaudible] one of the countries with the
highest prevalence around the world. I'm just
asking whether you have the strategy to make
sure that your prevalence doesn't go higher
than what you are right now. Thank you.